oui c'est ça je trouve toujours très
intéressant dans l'art de jonathan cohen
qui est pour moi un des plus grands
comiques de sa de sa génération et qui
est vraiment d'aller créer dans cette
forme parodique des des petits endroits
comme ça des personnages secondaires des
essais quelque chose comme ça comme un
laboratoire il ya l'apparition quand
même du personnage de marc collat ce
gang de cartel qui fait une sorte de
héros comme ça sur la télé réalité qui
la transforme en top chef il leur fait
faire de la cocaïne pardon de la farine
à trezeguet il ya une autre scène qui
est absolument admirable et je me suis
dit tiens je commence à comprendre ce
qui me plaît tellement chez ce
personnage c'est l'apparition par
miracle du personnage de jean guy toute
la cour on voir un personnage en voilà
qu'on a dont on n'a jamais entendu
parler dans l'émission et on revoit des
scènes dans lesquelles il n'était pas ça
me procure une adrénaline que je ne peux
trouver nulle part et au fil de ses 38
jours jean-guy est devenu le meilleur
ami de barques
qui se dévoue éliminés jean-guy j'ai
décidé de voter contre moi même
fait la couverture de match avec votre
ami avec une très belle interview je
n'ai jamais donné d'interview
qu'est ce que vous insinuez par là
devant tout le monde que les
journalistes montrent peut-être jamais
je dirais ça pour moi à ce moment là
j'ai vraiment commencé à voir une sorte
d'autoportrait joe nathan cohen en
enfants de la télé quelqu'un comme ça
qui aurait peut-être passé beaucoup de
temps je sais pas qui est à sa situation
familiale était le seul devant la télé à
se dire tiens où est mon frère où sont
mes parents et voilà il secret comme ça
des familles des liens affectifs à
travers ses différents personnages et
alors il ya une scène extraordinaire qui
est un moment où il rencontre une équipe
de locaux qui le kidnappe ils ont aussi
kidnappé le réalisateur frédéric lopez
le présentateur de en terre inconnue
évidemment ils ont fait le réalisateur
d'une telenovela donc regardez bien une
petite apparition de leïla bekhti qui
dira juste deux mots al pacino pour bien
une preneuse de son
émotion et la subtilité tu me fait
pleurer mec devrait
marquer 4 mais pour rien au monde je
reviendrai dans l'émission rien ici
regardez j'ai tout trouvé j'ai trouvé un
métier j'ai trouvé une famille qui
m'aiment pas comme les autres la haie et
même d'ailleurs plus qu'une famille je
crois que j'ai trouvé un public et sans
gloire m'avancer je crois que le public
est conquis à trouver un public trouver
une famille voilà la folie de l'enfant
de la télé après à l'ère de la société
du spectacle voilà qui s'est trouvé une
folie une famille à l'intérieur de la
télévision dans cette création visuelle
que je trouve parfois très voilà très
original et qui pourrait le devenir
encore plus